una competición deportiva sin igual a
orillas del nipro en kiev la mayoría de
sus participantes son soldados
ucranianos amputados que perdieron un
miembro en el frente tras el inicio de
la invasión rusa de Ucrania
los combates más intensos tuvieron lugar
en el interior de la fábrical en las
afueras de Mario Paul no se alcanzó un
misil antitanque y perdió una pierna te
mostraré cómo me la amputaron me
capturaron en estas condiciones
estos espectadores sentados en Primera
fila acaban de ser dados de alta del
hospital
este evento les da un cambio de aire
antes de comenzar Su rehabilitación
Nuestro objetivo es animar al mayor
número posible soldados a practicar
deporte y mejorar su situación sería una
gran Victoria para ellos
acudió al centro de prótesis tras
resultar herido al primer día de la
invasión rusa los médicos no pudieron
salvarle la pierna
cuando llevas muletas empiezas a pensar
que eres discapacitado cuando te ponen
las prótesis y empiezas a andar tienes
que aguantar el dolor porque las heridas
aún no han cicatrizado
hay que superar esta etapa y
sobreponerse al dolor es muy importante
trabajar con psicólogos
Sacha quiere seguir siendo optimista
lesionado hace más de un año ha venido
hoy aquí para probarse una prótesis de
fibra de carbono su intención es
representar a su país en una competición
deportiva internacional
lo que no nos mata nos hace más fuertes
tenemos que seguir adelante por eso
ganaremos
desde el inicio del conflicto Diez mil
heridos de guerra en Ucrania necesitan
ahora prótesis